the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
hi I unit today concerns something
called the dot product now it's very
easy to just mechanically give a
definition of the dot product but in
keeping with the spirit both of our game
and of our correlation between the real
and the abstract world let's keep in
mind that when it came time to define
vector addition we chose as our
definition a concept already used in the
physical world namely that of a
resultant vector and now what we would
like to do is to introduce a further
structure in our game of vectors and by
the way keep in mind that I do not need
any more physical interpretations to add
more complexities to my game but that
perhaps if we do this it makes the
subject more meaningful both to the
applied person and to the theoretical
person the ideas I wanted to keep in
mind for motivating today's lesson was
the hope the old high school idea of
work equals Force Times distance in the
elementary physics course well rather
than talk on like this let's just take a
look and see what's going on let's say
the lecture is called the dot product
and our physical motivation is the
recipe from elementary physics work
equals Force Times distance now this is
a deceptive little formula but first of
all what it really meant was when we
learned this recipe was that the force
was taking place in the same direction
as the object was moving now what
happened next was the following
situation we have an object say being
moved by a force the object is being
moved along a tabletop say the force is
represented now by a vector and arrow
and we're assuming enough friction here
so that the block moves along the table
and doesn't rise and the question is how
much work is done on the object as the
object moves say from this point to this
point now without worrying about what
motivates this thing physically the
important thing was is that people
observed that physically the only thing
that went into the work was the
component of the force in the direction
of the displacement in other words this
was the force that one found had to be
multiplied by the displacement in other
words to find the work being done one
took not the magnitude of F but rather
the component of F in the direction of s
and in this diagram that's just what
it's the magnitude of F times cosine
theta and that quantity which was called
the effective force was then multiplied
by the displacement and to write that in
more suggestive form notice that the
work was not the magnitude of the force
times the magnitude of the displacement
that was only true in the special case
where the force and the displacement
were in the same direction but that
rather the work is what it's the
magnitude of the force times the
magnitude of the displacement times the
cosine of the angle between the force
and the displacement and notice by the
way the very special cases that if F and
s happen to be parallel and have the
same sense then the angle between F and
s is zero the cosine of zero is one in
which case that you have the work is the
magnitude of the force times the
displacement the other extreme case
magnitude wise is if s and F happen to
be perpendicular in which case the angle
of course is 90 degrees the cosine of a
90 degree angle is zero in which case
what if the force was at right angles to
the displacement the work was zero at
any rate then whether we understand this
physical motivation there not as
irrelevant the important point is if we
want to keep this structure or this
particular motivation in a structural
form we now generalize this as follows
we simply say let a and B be any two
vector
arrows and we will define a dot B to be
the magnitude of a time's the magnitude
of B times the cosine of the angle
between a and B and I'll write this this
way
to indicate an ordering in other words
don't think of a and B as being a and B
think of a is denoting the first and B
is denoting the second vector and what
we're saying is the first dotted with
the second is the magnitude of the first
times the magnitude of the second times
the cosine of the angle as you rotate
the first vector in to the second and
the beauty of having a cosine over here
is the fact that what if you reverse the
angle of rotation in other words from B
into a notice that you change the sign
of the angle but the cosine of theta is
the same as cosine minus theta so no
harm is done this particular way on the
other hand had we been dealing with sine
of the angle as we will in our next
lecture this will make a difference but
be this as it may we define a dot B to
be the magnitude of a time's the
magnitude of V times the cosine of the
angle between a and B all right the two
extreme cases being what if a and B are
perpendicular the dot product is zero if
a and B are parallel the dot product is
equal to the magnitude of the product of
the two magnitudes now the only
difficult thing here are what we
sometimes call undesirable and maybe
this is what separates the new
three-dimensional geometry from the old
three-dimensional geometry is that the
cosine of an angle is particularly
difficult to keep track of especially
when the lines are in three-dimensional
space how do you measure an angle this
way you see in the plane it's simple you
draw the thing to scale but in 3-space
this can be rather difficult so what we
would like to do is to eliminate this
particular term we would like to find an
expression for a dot B that doesn't
involve the cosine of an angle at least
directly and to do this we simply draw a
little diagram and notice that even if a
and B are three dimensional vector
since a and B aligns if they are not
parallel if they M&A at a common point
they form a plane of their own let's
call that the plane of the blackboard
the third side of the triangle is either
a minus B or B minus a depending on
where you put the arrow head here but
we've already discussed that idea and
the interesting point here is notice
that a minus B very subtly includes the
angle theta in other words imagine the
magnitudes of a and B to be fixed and
now fan out a and B as you fan out a and
B what you're doing is what just
changing this angle as you change this
angle notice that a minus B changes
namely as these fan out the vector that
joins the two arrow heads here becomes a
different vector both in magnitude and
direction in other words whether it
looks at or not one of the beauties of
our vector notation is that the cosine
of the angle theta is indirectly
included in a minus B but now you see
once we have this triangle here notice
that the law of cosines tells us how to
relate the third side of a triangle in
terms of two sides and the included
angle okay and in fact when we use the
law of cosines notice that one of the
terms is going to be what the product of
the magnitudes of two sides times the
cosine of the included angle and that
roughly speaking is just what we mean by
a dot B so without any further ado what
we do now is we just write the law of
cosines down here which says what the
magnitude of a minus B squared is equal
to the magnitude of a squared plus the
magnitude of B squared minus twice the
magnitude of a time's the magnitude of B
times the cosine of the angle between a
and B and then you see we simply
recognize that this term here is by
definition a dot B we can now take this
equation and solve for a dot B which by
the way this is very very important to
notice I should have pointed this out
sooner but a dot B is a number it's the
product of two magnitudes times the
cosine of an angle
is a number this is a numerical equation
we can therefore solve for a dot B and
we wind up with what that a dot B is the
magnitude of a minus B squared minus the
magnitude of a squared minus the
magnitude of B squared all divided by
two and the beauty now is that we have
expressed a dot B solely in terms of
magnitudes and notice especially in
Cartesian coordinates I'll do that next
but in terms of Cartesian coordinates
notice that magnitudes are particularly
simple to find we just subtract
corresponding components and square etc
but the important point is that even
without Cartesian coordinates this
particular result expresses a dot B in
terms of the magnitudes of a B and a
minus B and is a result which is
independent of any coordinate system
however and this is done very simply in
the text reinforced in our exercises if
you elect to write a B and a minus B in
Cartesian coordinates and use this
particularly straightforward recipe what
we wind up with is a rather elegant
result elegant in terms of simplicity at
least and that is remember in Cartesian
coordinates we would write a as a 1 I
plus a 2 J plus a 3 K B would be B 1 I
plus B 2 J plus B 3 K and then the
beauty is what that a dot B turns out to
be very simply and conveniently a 1 B 1
plus a 2 B 2 plus a 3 B 3 in other words
that to dot a and B if the vectors are
written in Cartesian coordinates and
this is crucial if this is not done in
Cartesian coordinates you can get into a
heck of a mess and I have deliberately
made an exercise on this unit get you
into that mess if you fall into that
particular trap but if we have Cartesian
coordinates it turns out that two dot
two vectors you simply do what multiply
the two I components together multiply
the two J components together multiply
the two K components together and add
alright five
way to show you why this works from a
structural point of view without
belaboring this point right now notice
that if you were to multiply in the
usual sense of the word multiplication
form the dot product here you would
expect to get nine terms in other words
each of the terms in a multiplies each
of the three terms in B so it all
together you would expect nine terms the
thing that's rather interesting here is
that notice that I dot I J dot J and K
dot k all happen to be one because after
all the magnitudes of these vectors are
each one the angle between I and I is
zero J and J is zero the angle between K
and K is zero so that I dot I JJ and K
dot k are all 1 whereas on the other
hand when you take mixed terms notice
that because I and J I and K and J and K
are all at right angles I dot J JK I dot
K are all going to be 0 and that
therefore those other six terms will
drop out in other words structurally
what's happening here is the fact that
the three vectors that we're using here
all happen to have unit length and they
happen to be mutually perpendicular if
they were not perpendicular these mixed
terms would occur in here in other words
in general when you dot two vectors the
pet in three space depending on the
coordinate system you can expect up to
nine terms in your answer but the beauty
is that as long as we have Cartesian
coordinates that happens to be a
particularly simple beautiful recipe to
compute a dot B now keep in mind the a
dot B that we're talking about here is
the same one that we define before it's
the magnitude of a time's the magnitude
of B times the cosine of the angle
between a and B all we're saying is that
if we use Cartesian coordinates we can
compute it almost as fast as we can read
and let me show you that in terms of
some examples my first example is the
following let's imagine that we have
three points in Cartesian three space a
is the point 1 comma 2 comma 3 B is the
point 2 comma 4 comma 1 and C is the
point 3 comma
zero comma four we draw the straight
lines a B and a C and we would like to
find the angle BAC in other words the
angle theta the first thing that we do
and this is one of the beauties of how
vectors are used in geometry is that we
vectorize the lines a and B we put
arrowheads on them that immediately
makes them vectors we already know from
last time how to read the vectors a B
and a C namely a B is the vector I plus
2j C just subtract component by
component 2 minus 1 is 1 4 minus 2 is 2
1 minus 3 is minus 3 etc so the vector a
B is the vector I plus 2 J minus 2 K and
the vector AC working in a similar way
is 2i minus 2j plus K now the beauty is
that we can compute these magnitudes
very very quickly by recipe and we've
just linked a recipe for finding a dot B
in a hurry I mean eight well in this
case I don't mean a dot B I mean the
vector a B dotted with the vector AC and
going through the computational details
here we square the components of a B
extract the positive square root and we
find very easily that the magnitude of a
B is three and the hardest part of these
problems as for me as a teacher is to
find ones where I find the sum of three
squares coming out to be a whole number
so I always use the vector 1 2 - that's
a nice vector that way similarly the
vector AC also happens to have magnitude
3 ok and to find a B dot a C what do we
do let's just come back here and make
sure we know what we're doing now we
simply dot component by component it's 1
times 2 plus 2 times minus 2 plus minus
2 times 1 in other words a B dot a C is
2 minus 4 minus 2 which is minus 4 now
using our recipe we see what that cosine
theta is a ba ba C divided by the
product of the magnitudes of a B and AC
from which we very quickly
glued that the cosine of theta is minus
4/9 and if you're still mixed up as to
what that minus sign means just by way
of a quick review of the inverse
trigonometric functions you locate the
point minus 4 comma 9 in the XY plane
and your angle theta is this particular
angle here which means that in terms of
principal values if you look up the
angle in the tables whose cosine is 4/9
that will give you this angle here
subtract that from 180 and that's the
angle that you're looking for but the
beauty is what that you can now find the
coast you can now find an angle between
two lines in space without having to
geometrically worry about what the angle
looks like the algebra in cartesian
coordinates
takes care of this by itself the same
thing happens when you're looking for
projections in three-dimensional space
suppose you have a force and a
displacement in three-dimensional space
and you want to project a force onto a
line a direction and our next example
shows how the dot product can be used to
find projections namely his a vector a
his a vector B and I would like to
project the vector a onto the vector B
and I would like to find what the length
of that projection is well from
elementary trigonometry I know that the
length of this projection is just the
magnitude of a time's the cosine of
theta and by the way notice of theta
were greater than 90 degrees cosine
theta would be negative and the minus
sign would not affect the length it
would simply tell us that the projection
was in the opposite sense of B that's
all that would mean but here's the
interesting point if you look at the
magnitude of a time's the cosine of
theta it almost looks like a dot product
after all
theta is the angle between a and B and
if the magnitude of B were in here this
would just be a dot B but the magnitude
of B isn't in here of course if the
magnitude of B happened to be 1 that
would be fine but the magnitude of B
might not be 1 and the most honest way
to make it 1 is to divide B by its
magnitude and that will
give you if you divide any vector by its
magnitude that automatically gives you a
unit vector having the same direction
and sense as the vector that you started
with in other words let u sub B which is
the magnet which is B divided by its
magnitude be the unit vector in the
direction and by the way here Direction
include sense in a direction of B and
notice that the unit vector in the
direction of B has the same direction as
B itself therefore to find the angle
between u sub DNA is the same as finding
the angle between B na in other words
the kicker now seems to be that I take
this length which is the magnitude of a
times cosine theta and rewrite that as
follows it's the magnitude of a and now
remembering that u sub B has unit length
I just struggling as a factor and theta
being the angle between a and B is also
the angle between a and u sub B but this
by definition is a dot u sub B you see
in other words to find the projection of
a onto B all you have to do is dot a
with the unit vector in the direction of
B in fact to summarize that without the
use of B in there all I'm saying is
given two vectors a and B if u dot a and
B and then divide by the magnitude of B
that will be the projection of a in the
direction of B okay the projection of a
in the direction of B and of course if
you want the other way around you have
to reverse the roles of a and B the
beauty of this unit in Cartesian
coordinates is how easy it is to compute
a dot B in Cartesian coordinates oh
another example that you might be
interested in but I think is very
interesting and that's the special case
where a and B already happened to be
unit vectors if a and B already happen
to be unit vectors then if we use our
recipe of a from the formula for a dot B
we observe that in this case by
definition of unit vectors both the
magnitudes of a and B are 1 and we find
that a dot B is then the coast
of the angle between a and B which means
that if a and B happen to be unit
vectors as soon as you dot them you have
automatically found the cosine of the
angle between the two vectors which
suggests a rather general type of
approach given any two vectors divide
each by the magnitude right that gives
you unit vectors dot them and that gives
you the cosine of the angle between them
you see in particular and here's an
interesting thing you know I I love is
that funny it says struck me as funny
last last night at supper as we're
sitting down to eat my four-year-old
looked at me and said dad did they have
baked potatoes when you was a little boy
and you get the feeling sometimes that
people think that the modern world
really changed the old in certain basic
ways that didn't happen at all and one
of the interesting points is is that
long before vector geometry was invented
people were doing three-dimensional
geometry using non vector methods and
one technique that happened to be used
with things called directional cosines
namely suppose you were given a line in
space okay as a vector if you wish to
look at it that way or if you didn't
want look at it as a vector imagine the
line parallel to the given line that
goes through the origin as soon as I
know what that line looks like I can
compute the angle that it makes with the
positive x-axis I can compute the angle
that it makes with the positive y-axis I
can compute the angle that it makes with
the positive z-axis and those three
angles uniquely determine the position
of the line in space the direction of
the line okay and those were called
the coasts the directional angles you
understand that was the
three-dimensional analog of slope in
other words to find the slope of a line
in three-dimensional space draw the line
parallel to that line that goes through
the origin and measure each of the three
angles that that line makes with the
positive x y and z-axes and what the
beauty was of the dot product was it
just gave us a simpler way of doing that
namely if a is
any vector I divide a by its magnitude
that gives me the unit vector in the
direction of a if I now dot the unit
vector in the direction of a with I and
after all what is I I is the unit vector
in the direction of the positive x-axis
since these are both unit vectors this
will be the cosine of the angle between
I and a and that's just what the cosine
of the angle that a makes with the
positive x-axis traditionally that acts
that angle was called alpha so you a dot
I is simply cosine alpha correspondingly
you AJ is the cosine of the angle
between a and J that's the cosine of the
angle that a makes with the positive
y-axis that angle was called beta this
is cosine beta and u sub a K is cosine
gamma where gamma is the angle that a
makes with the positive K direction and
these being the cosines of the angles
these were called the directional
cosines and they yielded the slope of
lines but one must not believe that one
needed vectors before he could do
three-dimensional geometry what did
happen was that vector techniques
greatly simplified many of the aspects
of three-dimensional geometry well let's
leave this part for a moment and close
for today by coming back to our game
idea remember that ultimately all we
will ever use once we get started with
our game all we will ever use are the
structural properties now I've gone
through these in the notes I've gone
through them while you go through them
with me in the text or with yourselves
in the text let me just point out
certain properties of the dot product
that I shared by regular arithmetic as
well for example a dot B equals B dot a
the dot product is commutative why is
that well think of what a dot B is it's
the magnitude of a time's the magnitude
of B times the cosine of the angle
between a and B but that's the same as
what the magnitude of B times the
magnitude of a after all numbers
no our commutative when you multiply
them and the cosine of the angle between
a and B is the same as the cosine of the
angle between B and a so these are equal
numerical quantities again without going
through the proof here it turns out that
if you want a dot a vector with the sum
of two given vectors the distributive
property holds namely a dot B plus C is
a dot B plus a dot C by the way if you
did want to prove this all you would
have to do if you couldn't see it
geometrically is to argue as follows you
say you know the easiest way to add and
dot vectors is in Cartesian coordinates
so let me prove that this result is true
in Cartesian coordinates carry out the
details and if it works in Cartesian
coordinates since the result doesn't
depend on the coordinate system the
result must be true regardless of the
coordinate system but it's a very simple
exercise to actually write a B and C in
terms of IJ K components compute both
sides of this expression and show that
they're numerically equal I say
numerically because it's crucial to
notice that both expressions on either
side of the equal sign are numbers B
plus C is a vector a is a vector when
you dot two vectors you get a number
finally a scalar multiple of a vector
dotted with another vector has the
property that you can leave the scalar
multiple outside in other words you can
first dot the two vectors and then
multiply by the scalar in other words in
a way you can you don't have to worry
about voice inflection when you have a
scalar multiple and we will talk more
about these as we go along however
what's very crucial is to notice that
the dot product does have some
difficulties not associated with
ordinary multiplication so I say beware
for example somebody might say I wonder
if the dot product is associative I
wonder if a dot B dollar would see is
the same as a dotted would be dotted
would see and this is nonsensical i I
want to do this with great dramatic
but I probably would have broken two
fingers against the board here let's
just cross this out so she won't be
inclined to remember that this not only
is false it's stupid and the reason that
it's stupid is that it's nonsensical
that these things don't make sense
namely the dot product has been defined
to be an operation between two vectors
that yields a number notice that as soon
as you dot a and B you no longer have a
vector you have a number and you cannot
dot a number with a vector in other
words neither a dot B dot C nor a dot B
dot C is defined because you see a
number is never dotted with a vector all
right and finally a closing note as
we've already seen if a is perpendicular
to B then the cosine of the angle
between a and B is 0 and that says that
if a is perpendicular to B then a dot B
is 0 in fact this is one of the most
common usages on the elementary level of
the dot product is to prove that two
vectors are perpendicular but whereas
that's a nice property
what causes great hardship here is to
notice the following in particular that
if a dot B is 0 we cannot conclude that
either a is the zero vector or B is the
zero vector for example I dot J is zero
but neither I nor J is the zero vector
you see with ordinary arithmetic we had
the cancellation rule things that said
if the product of two numbers is zero at
least one of the factors must be zero
with the dot product this need not be
true the thing I want you to get from
this lesson more than anything else
other than the applications that you can
get from the book and from the exercises
is to learn to get a feeling for the
structure don't be upset that certain
vector properties are different then
arithmetic properties and certain ones
are the same notice in terms of the game
we take our rules as they may apply and
just carry them out towards inescapable
conclusions but I think that will become
clearer as you read the text and do the
exercises and until next time when we'll
talk about a new vector product
to say so long funding for the
publication of this video was provided
by the Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate